[APPLAUSE]
LANG LANG: Good morning.
Thanks for being here.
I'm very happy to be here
for the second time.
But the first time I wasn't
on this stage.
I was just visiting
the office.
It's a very cool office,
I must say.
And so I prepared some morning
songs for you to wake up.
So a few Chopin pieces.
I will start with one of the
very beautiful nocturnes and
then one or two etudes, and
then a Chopin waltz.
So hopefully, we will get really
waked after 20 minutes
of performance.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[PIANO MUSIC - CHOPIN]
JEFF SPURGEON: Hello, I'm Jeff
Spurgeon from WQXR, New York's
classical station, 105.9
FM, online at wqxr.org.
You may not know, because
nobody told you,
this is Lang Lang.
He's a classical pianist,
reasonably well known
all over the globe.
And it's quite a wonderful
thing to hear you play.
Let me ask you, what was
your warm-up for
this just this morning?
Did you warm up this morning?
When's the last time you
touched a piano?
LANG LANG: I didn't warm up.
I woke up around 10:20.
I'm like, oh, god.
And we were running like crazy
down the street to get here.
And I'm really grateful
that you are here
today waiting for me.
And thank you very much.
JEFF SPURGEON: It's
really wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF SPURGEON: It's
extraordinary to have all that
music just in your hands,
just at your command.
But that's what you do.
LANG LANG: By the way,
Rubinstein said-- one of the
greatest pianists.
And he said he has 60 piano
concertos in his head.
And basically during his
70s or 80s he said
just call me up.
Wake me up in the middle
of the night-- like,
let's say, 4:00 AM--
and I can play whatever piece
you want, in concert level.
JEFF SPURGEON: Well,
I believe it.
But so can you.
He had a little more practice
over time than you so far.
But you'll be there.
In China, Lang Lang is credited
with influencing some
40 million kids to take
up classical piano.
Now, I know that 40 million
is not maybe a
huge number at Google.
But still, it's a reasonably
large number of people to
persuade to take up.
And when you think about all
the pianos that have to be
made, and all the music that has
to be printed, and all the
lessons that have to be paid
for, I would say that you are,
without question, classical
music's greatest job creator.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF SPURGEON: I don't think
there's anybody who's going to
do more than that
than you are.
Lang Lang's new album on the
Sony label is "The Chopin
Album." It contains, at its
heart, the Opus 25 set of a
dozen etudes, studies for piano,
that you have been
studying since I think
you were what?
Eight is when you started
to play those things?
LANG LANG: Yeah, I started
to play the Chopin
Etudes when I was eight.
JEFF SPURGEON: Took them
on the road when
you were 12 or 13?
LANG LANG: Yeah, I played the
complete etudes when I was 13.
JEFF SPURGEON: Right.
LANG LANG: And it was very
tiring to play those pieces.
I mean, it drives me nuts and
drives my neighbors nuts.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: I really feel
bad about it, you know.
Recently, I started practicing
at my apartment here and
started practicing the
Chopin etudes.
And then my neighbor
knocked at my door.
And he said could you stop?
Could you stop?
JEFF SPURGEON: Really?
Did they really?
You're making that up.
LANG LANG: No, no.
I mean, there's a one neighbor
who knows who I am, so she's
always like, oh, that's
really wonderful.
But then another neighbor, I
think, living downstairs--
because I always like to
practice after 11:00 to find
inspiration.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: And this
lady, I think she
hate me all the time.
JEFF SPURGEON: So you've been
playing these since you were
eight, playing them in public
since you were 13.
Why record them now?
Why not a little earlier?
Why not wait a couple
more years?
Maybe the wine will mellow a
little more in the bottle.
Why decide to do these now?
LANG LANG: Ever since I'm 30,
I like to do some more
repertoire which I played a lot
when I was a kid and also
putting in some new pieces.
I actually thought to
do the 24 etudes to
complete the cycle.
But actually, I thought maybe
I should do something, not
just technical pieces, but
also very artistic pieces
combined for the Chopin
first solo for me to
record and also to hear.
I was actually watching the
video that I did when I was
13, playing the complete
etudes.
And I find a few wrong notes.
I'm like, yeah.
But I'm now playing a few of
those pieces, like the "Winter
Wind" and the "Ocean" etudes.
Now it feels slightly easier--
slightly.
So that seems like
a good sign.
After 17 years of practice, my
technique is going somewhere.
But more importantly, it's
the musical sense.
There are so many new things
I'm trying to interpret in
this album to try to find
different colors, like you
have here, different levels of
colors and the combination of
the styling of Chopin, and the
romantic period of repertoire.
And especially last
year, I did Liszt.
So I thought this was a nice
momentum to do Chopin.
So next year will be
very different.
JEFF SPURGEON: What's
next year?
LANG LANG: Next year I will
do Prokofiev and Bartok.
JEFF SPURGEON: Wow.
OK.
LANG LANG: So it's very,
very different--
JEFF SPURGEON: Gnarly.
LANG LANG: --approach.
JEFF SPURGEON: Yeah,
totally different.
A totally different world.
There's some unusual pieces
on this album.
The "Andante spianato" and
"Grande polonaise." big
favorite of yours, done with
orchestra sometimes, but
there's the solo version.
You've always liked
this piece?
LANG LANG: Not really.
I mean, when I was a
kid, I hated it.
Because no matter how great the
works are, if there are so
many pianists playing the same
piece not at a very good
level, then you will
feel kind of bored.
And so that exactly happened
when I was a kid.
I heard so many interpretations
of this piece
that I got totally
overwhelmed.
And I didn't like it.
Then I came to America.
And I studied at Curtis
in Philadelphia.
Do you know the Philly
cheese steak?
It's pretty good.
Anyway, in Philadelphia, a boy
from Kiev, he also studied
with the same teacher as
me, Gary Graffman.
JEFF SPURGEON: Gary Graffman.
LANG LANG: And he played
in the student recital.
I was shocked by his playing.
I'm like, wow, this piece
is spectacular.
And then I started to
loving this piece.
Thanks to him, of course.
And so sometimes one amazing
performance really changes
your entire view of a work.
And that's what happened in
the "Spianato" and "Grande
polonaise."
JEFF SPURGEON: Nocturnes.
You played, actually, a
wonderful cross-section of the
album just a few minutes ago.
There's a piece on this album.
It's the last selection.
It's called "Tristesse." And it
features a singer named Oh
Land who is from--
LANG LANG: Sweden, I think.
JEFF SPURGEON: Sweden.
She lives in Williamsburg,
because most people do.
LANG LANG: Yeah, Brooklyn's
getting big.
JEFF SPURGEON: It's beautiful.
And can you tell me
the story of this?
Because it's from a
film, "Tristesse."
LANG LANG: Right.
We did a film during the Chopin
year called "The Flying
Machine." So it's basically
adapted to a novel about
Poland today.
And it's compared to
Chopin's days.
So actually, I was an
actor in this movie.
And my partner was Heather
Graham from "Austin
Powers," the girl.
JEFF SPURGEON: Yeah,
Heather Graham.
Many, many faces lit up when
you said those words.
LANG LANG: But that one
was pretty classic.
I need a hungover thing.
I miss the baby, yeah.
And so that film, actually, was
quite inspiring, because
it was Chopin's music,
and takes the
journey of a piano, actually.
The piano became a
flying machine.
So we take the kids
over the world.
And so the theme song, we
actually thought the
"Tristesse," which is Opus 10,
Number 3, etudes, is such a
beautiful melody, which I played
second to the last.
And so we transcribed that to
the theme song, so we got this
beautiful voice.
Her name is pretty
fun, Oh Land.
So in the beginning, I didn't
know if it's a he or a she.
Then when I heard the voice, I
most certainly said, it's she.
And she did a wonderful job.
JEFF SPURGEON: It's
a sweet song.
And a lot of popular
songs have been
written on Chopin themes.
LANG LANG: Yes.
JEFF SPURGEON: And this is
another one, which is great.
Your foundation, let's talk
about that because that's such
a big deal.
The Lang Lang International
Music Foundation, it's going
great guns.
You had some kids, I think, from
part of that program on
"The Tonight Show" recently?
LANG LANG: Yeah, two weeks
ago, I was on Jay Leno.
JEFF SPURGEON: Four minutes of
classical music on network
television.
It was extraordinary.
It was four whole minutes.
It was amazing.
LANG LANG: These days,
it's hard to get
classical music on--
JEFF SPURGEON: That's
exactly right.
LANG LANG: Anyway, I mean,
Jay is a good friend.
And I mean, his name is Jay
Jay now, you know, after--
JEFF SPURGEON: After
Lang Lang.
Right, sure.
LANG LANG: Oh, my god,
he has 400 cars.
Anyway, let's not
talk about that.
So we actually had a very
fortunate selection of
wonderful tenants from
the Los Angeles area.
I mean, some of the kids,
actually, I know them before,
because they performed with me,
my foundation, actually.
JEFF SPURGEON: They were
young kids, too.
There were 10 of them.
So Lang Lang played.
You play some "La companella,"
and the E-flat waltz that you
heard part of here.
And then 10 kids, five other
Steinways around in the room,
and they all joined you for the
Mozart "Ronda alla Turca."
LANG LANG: Yeah, Turkish
March [HUMS TUNE].
I'm sure you know it.
And it was so beautiful
that I really enjoyed
working with them.
But the way they played,
it was magnificent.
JEFF SPURGEON: Yeah,
very sweet.
LANG LANG: And I mean, I thought
everyone watching our
next generation perform,
it's a special moment.
And for me, it's
very inspiring.
And that's what our foundation
is wanting to do, to work with
the next generation of artists,
and helping them to
support them to achieve their
dreams, just like many of the
mentor helped me when
I was very young.
JEFF SPURGEON: So it's about
helping the next generation,
not necessarily about
classical music.
I mean, it is classical
focused, I think.
LANG LANG: Yeah, it will be a
focus on classical and piano.
But at the same time, we will
also do some event, let's say,
with the Grammy people
and VHI people.
So we are trying to break the
boundaries through this
wonderful project.
And I created this 101
Pianists project.
JEFF SPURGEON: You have 100
pianists with you on stage?
Is that the idea?
LANG LANG: Yes.
And 50 pianos, so people
play four hands.
So the reason is that--
JEFF SPURGEON: That's also a
great job creator, too, just
for the movers.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: Yeah, the movers
were quite happy about it.
But the reason we want it is
that as a pianist, we always
practice by ourselves.
It's sometimes very lonely.
You are in a dark room, much
darker than this room.
And I practice hours, hours.
And it's hard training.
And for kids, it's important
to have a partner.
So two kids on one piano, so
they can talk a little bit.
It's like doing your homework,
that type of thing.
And then the teachers can teach
them how to play together.
And in the end, we all
get together and play
and enjoy the music.
JEFF SPURGEON: The music-making,
yeah.
October 30 at Carnegie Hall,
the Lang Lang International
Music Foundation is having a
big benefit concert in the
evening with Joshua Bell, and
Dee Dee Bridgewater, and the
formerly mentioned Oh Land.
LANG LANG: And Alec Baldwin.
JEFF SPURGEON: And Alec Baldwin
will be the host.
And some scholars.
So what's going to happen
that night?
Just a big bunch of music
making, I guess?
LANG LANG: Yeah.
JEFF SPURGEON: Do you
collaborate with everybody?
Are you doing something with
Dee Dee Bridgewater?
LANG LANG: Yeah.
So here I start to
play some Chopin.
And then with Josh, we play
the Grieg Piano Sonata.
JEFF SPURGEON: Is he Jay
Jay also to you?
LANG LANG: Josh Josh.
JEFF SPURGEON: OK,
just checking.
LANG LANG: And then in the
second half, we start with
four hands, six hands, eight
hands, and 10 hands.
JEFF SPURGEON: On one piano?
LANG LANG: No.
JEFF SPURGEON: OK,
just checking.
Just checking.
LANG LANG: Yeah, 10 hands
on one piano.
JEFF SPURGEON: Well, you'd know
each other very well by
the end of the piece.
You'd be very familiar.
LANG LANG: Sounds like subway
in New York, yeah?
JEFF SPURGEON: That's right.
You are a master.
At the age of 30,
you are a master
recognized around the globe.
But are you still a student?
And do you see any of
your old teachers?
Gary Graffman was your
teacher at Curtis.
I know you've done
a little bit of
work with Daniel Barenboim.
LANG LANG: Absolutely.
JEFF SPURGEON: When you see
them, do you play for them and
ask them for their thoughts?
Is it a lesson?
Do they give you notes?
How does it work at this level
where you are in your stage of
artistry with these
older mentors, I
guess you'd call them?
LANG LANG: Yeah, I mean,
my teachers were--
and still are--
Gary Graffman, Christoph
Eschenbach, Daniel Barenboim.
And they helped me tremendously,
not just
technically.
JEFF SPURGEON: I was going to
say, they're not going to say,
you missed the E-flat
on the 40th bar.
That's not what they do.
So what do they--
LANG LANG: Well, sometimes
they do that, too.
But because the great musicians,
like those names,
they are much more focused on
the understanding and also on
the traditional interpretations,
so they will
show you how the traditional
sound.
And then we will start
discussing about new
possibilities of how we recreate
those moments, the
traditional lines.
And then they will help me
to find out my ways.
I will start to explore some of
my ideas on those passages
how I'm going to do it.
And obviously, we know that in
music, there are certain
styles, but there's
not certain rules.
And so basically there are
a lot of alternatives.
And the important thing is how
to organize the alternatives
and how to balance them,
having a right pause.
And this is the challenge
because you can do a lot of
interpretations.
But even it doesn't balance, if
it in the end doesn't make
sense, then all those
feelings are wasted.
And so first, you should
explore, and then you need to
limit your interpretations
into certain ways.
And then in the concert, you
start everything new again,
try to get inspired from the
actual stage and to recreate
new feelings, new emotion, but
aware of the tradition lines,
which will hold every
interpretation in the right
speed and right pause.
JEFF SPURGEON: Well, you're
part of that tradition.
You're recreating
it and making it
new at the same time.
I should say, too, that there's
time for questions
from all of you here at
the end a little bit.
Just think of your question.
LANG LANG: Hold the line,
hold the line.
JEFF SPURGEON: Yeah, exactly.
I've wondered about the
transition from Chinese
culture to Western culture for
you in music as well, because
you grew up playing this music
for a very long time.
For me, Chinese classical music
is a little bit strange
and maybe a little bit difficult
to listen to,
because I haven't had as much
experience with it.
You've been steeped in
both traditions.
Do you hear them the same way?
Or do you switch sort of
from one to another?
And you've put them
together, too.
Because you've done lots of
piano transcriptions of
traditional Chinese pieces
that weren't
thought of on the piano.
LANG LANG: Just like this, when
you hear American music,
when you hear German music, when
you hear African music,
it's different.
But at the same time, it's
all called music.
It's like language, you know.
In the end we try to expressing
similar subjects,
similar feelings, but using
different wording and
different language.
That's a bit like
the music world.
I mean, obviously, you need to
switch fast with the taste of
music making.
But in the end of the day, for
example, I grew up both in
Chinese traditional music and
the Western classical, because
my father plays erhu, which
is Chinese melody.
Recently, I found a different
interesting thing of the
difference between a fork and
chopsticks and the difference
between erhu and violin.
Do you see the similarity?
JEFF SPURGEON: Yeah,
I understand.
LANG LANG: The erhu
has two strings.
And violin has four.
And chopsticks--
JEFF SPURGEON: Two.
A fork, usually four tines.
LANG LANG: So here I go.
So that's the difference.
JEFF SPURGEON: Very good.
That's a very good answer.
I mean, one of the things with
your foundation, you're
helping people to explore
classical music.
Do you feel like you can make
people like classical music?
I feel like sometimes
it's a sales job.
Nobody says, oh my god, you've
got to hear rock and roll.
You won't believe what
this stuff is.
Nobody says it.
But about classical music,
sometimes people say, oh,
well, if you haven't heard it,
you should maybe listen to a
little bit of it.
Do you feel like you're
ever having to sell
it, the idea of it?
LANG LANG: I mean,
one experience I
got was pretty funny--
two experiences.
The first was seen in America,
and then I'll
talk about China later.
So first, in America.
I came when I was 15.
And then I was in a regular high
school in Philadelphia,
all those dudes and [INAUDIBLE],
you know.
And then they asked
me, what do you do
here in this country?
Oh, I'm studying classical
music.
They were like, classical
music?
What is that?
Oh, I know, I know.
Are you playing the dudes
who's already passed
like 500 years ago?
You do his work?
I say, yeah, it's kind
of like that.
I said, just think about
Shakespeare.
He's dead for many years.
He passed, but still his work
is a classic, right?
So then I know we have
a serious problem.
And then a few years
later, I went back
to China for concerts.
And then during the CD signings,
this one guy came
and was like, I saw that
you are recording the
same label as Mozart.
So you see, it's totally
opposite.
But somehow, it's quite funny.
So in a way, that gives us the
room to have some work to do.
But I don't think we need
to sell this art because
classical music is
so wonderful.
People sometimes don't know it.
That's it.
We just need to--
using social media networks
and platforms.
JEFF SPURGEON: Can you give an
example of social media?
Just kidding.
It's Google Talks.
It's Google.
Sorry.
LANG LANG: Yeah, I mean,
remember a few years ago,
YouTube had a YouTube symphony
orchestra competition?
And it was a big phenomenon
on the internet.
And I had a great privilege
to be the
ambassador for the project.
And so in the future--
today even, when I tweet
or Facebooking--
I start to share some of the
musical thoughts, not just
talking about food and movies,
but to share a little bit of
feelings to the music I play.
And then I share some of my
favorite links of the great
musicians perform to try to
inspire some fans to listen.
JEFF SPURGEON: Very
good, thank you.
All right.
There are microphones
over there.
So if you have questions, please
go to a microphone.
And we'll line you up and knock
you down with Lang Lang.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Samir.
I'm here at Google.
I am a father.
I've got a five-year-old
and a two-year-old.
And for better or worse, my kids
are into popular music.
LANG LANG: Good for you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm wondering--
so making them sit down and
listen to better music, to
classical music, feels a
little heavy handed.
LANG LANG: Oh, thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: It feels a little
heavy handed.
I was wondering, what have you
found really works with kids
to get them engaged and
interested in new kinds of
music, in particular,
classical music?
LANG LANG: There are a few
composers which I felt quite
have a really good connection
to kids.
One is Tchaikovsky, pieces like
"Nutcracker" or "Swan
Lake." And Mozart, Mozart
probably is the best composer
to inspire the kids.
And Chopin, also, I would
say is melodic.
But you wouldn't start with
Wagner's "Ring Cycle," right?
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: That's
a little hard.
So good luck.
Maybe there's some new
Lady Gaga coming out.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, quick question.
Along those lines, I have a
four and a six-year-old.
LANG LANG: Baby time.
AUDIENCE: And they just start
and stop things, especially my
six-year-old daughter.
She's interested now in piano.
How do I get that going,
keep that going?
Because I imagine there will be
challenges along the way.
LANG LANG: First, get
a good teacher.
That's very important.
And very important, if you have
time, please take her to
a kids event, a kids concert.
I'm sure Carnegie does
a lot of those
things and Lincoln Center.
Or take her to some
of the concerts
that other kids perform.
Because for me, it
was the same.
The reason I start liking
performance when I was very
young is because all my friends
were musicians, and
they were actually playing
something.
And we can actually play
together, like, two pianos or
three pianos.
Or violin, play a trio,
a little trio.
And music's like language.
We need a communication.
We need to use our language.
You know, if you learn a new
language, if you don't use it,
you're not interested, and
you forget about it.
So communication is
very important.
JEFF SPURGEON: I know there's
at least one more question.
AUDIENCE: I think I could
just ask here.
JEFF SPURGEON: I'll repeat it.
AUDIENCE: First of all, as a
Chinese, I am very proud of
your-- you know, everything.
LANG LANG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Like [INAUDIBLE].
Really good job.
My question is do you have any
plan to do some record like
Bach or something more classic
like "Goldberg--"
LANG LANG: "Goldberg
Variation."
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like
like that.
JEFF SPURGEON: OK, so the
question was what are your
plans for your next
recordings?
And will you do Bach,
specifically?
LANG LANG: I mean,
I love Bach.
When I was a kid, I played
Bach's work every week.
And I tried to memorize
a work by Bach every
week to train my brain.
By the way, after that, you can
remember every cellphone
number you want.
And Bach is really, really
challenging, but incredible.
Certainly, I would love to
record the "Goldberg
Variation." Certainly,
I will do more
classic repertoire records.
But it needs to be balanced.
So this year and last year
I did all the romantics.
And then next year, it
will be contemporary.
And then, you know.
So I'm trying to balance
the recordings.
Thanks for bringing the
"Goldberg," by the way.
AUDIENCE: So there's a
lot of talk about--
sorry, I'm very tall.
There's a lot of talk
about bringing
classical music to children.
And I am, in some sense,
a product of that.
My father went way out of his
way to play classical music.
He really enjoyed it.
And I hated it as a kid.
And I'm here.
So that's obviously no
longer the case.
But I studied, or at least I was
taught, classical guitar.
And that lapsed for several
years while I went to
university.
And now I'm here, so I guess
the lapse was a little
worthwhile.
But what advice would you give
towards adults who have a
musical sensibility, who have
musical appreciation and, I
guess in my case, have or, in
more general cases, do not
have some degree of
musical training?
Because children are taught at
a very early age to begin to
play classical music or
any music in general.
Is there any fear that I should
have in terms of lack
of dexterity, I guess,
plasticity of mind?
What advice would you give
towards adults who want to
begin to hopefully, with a lag,
reach the kind of level
you operate on?
LANG LANG: You are
getting deep.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: Wow.
Adult.
I mean, there's an app called
Magic Piano, which I
co-produced.
If you feel difficult to play
the real piano, try that.
It will be easier to play.
Because somehow it's
played by itself.
And you can certainly buy a
piano which has a kind of
high-tech disk.
And then you just push whoever's
Chopin, whoever's
Tchaikovsky, whoever's
Beethoven.
And then you can maybe start to
see the positions down on
the piano and try
to follow it.
But again, I am really welcoming
of adults actually
learning an instrument.
And especially, you
had a musical
training before, right?
So for you, it will be very
easy, actually, to pick it up
again, the great work
you did before.
And maybe now when you do
it, you will feel more
comfortable.
Maybe you will like it more
than when you were a kid.
And also, you know, classical
guitar is pretty cool.
And I'm sure when you
play, you get some
new dates or something.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: I mean, that's
very encouraging.
I know some of my friends, who
are adults, study piano.
I say, why are you doing it?
Oh, I to impress the girls.
So I know lots of
those people.
So it's good encouragement.
JEFF SPURGEON: Choice of
instrument could be important
for that, too.
You'll get more dates with
a guitar, probably,
than with an accordion.
Just a thought.
LANG LANG: Guitar is very
popular these days.
Probably one of the instruments
I can think of
more popular than piano,
it's probably guitar.
I would like to learn
it, actually.
Guitar, I mean.
Maybe I should learn
some classical
guitar skill from you.
AUDIENCE: I'd love
to give you a--
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: I got new
lessons from you.
AUDIENCE: So the point is a
competent teacher, right?
LANG LANG: Great.
Thank you.
JEFF SPURGEON: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask, when
you memorize a piece, is
it only technical?
Or do you also memorize
how you feel?
Is it like, before you start
playing, do you have to get
into the emotion
of that piece?
Or is just the music getting
you there when you hear it?
LANG LANG: First, sometimes I
hear great music in my ear.
Whether it's any type of music,
I'm just trying to
memorize the melodies first.
And I want to somehow play
it on the piano.
But some work, I know it for
many years, and it doesn't
mean that you start to love
those repertoire right away.
Some pieces take a few
years to digest.
And then you're like,
wow, I should do it.
So first comes to the
general stuff.
You read a score after you're
really liking this piece.
You want to learn it, right?
So you learn it from the score,
and you play simply,
whether just play by your
right hand or putting it
together, practice.
And after that, you are trying
to analyzing the piece and
using everything you learned
from the past.
And your head should be like
a multimedia screen.
Try to pick a lot of elements
and try to put those things
inside of the music.
Because the most important
thing is not the note.
It's the things behind
the note, the
meaning behind the note.
So the more meanings you're
getting, it's better for the
first work session.
And then later, you're
just trying to
balance the right ones.
And you will know the right
ones when you are ready.
In the beginning, you
don't really know.
So you try a lot of things.
And then later you will know,
wow, this will not work.
Because this maybe doesn't
fit in the style.
And then later, after you really
understand the dynamics
of the score, you start
to recreate things.
And then you play for several
of your teachers or your
colleagues to get more ideas.
And then you start looking
into this work again.
And then you start
performance.
And when you perform, every day,
every time, you should
try different things.
And after a year, I think, you
are ready for recording.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LANG LANG: Lot of
alternatives.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Zettai.
I work in Google.
And I actually have the opposite
problem from Samir
with my two-and-a-half
year-old daughter.
She actually loves
classical music.
LANG LANG: Yay!
Here we go, yeah.
AUDIENCE: She even goes to sleep
while hearing Andrea
Bocelli and you playing there,
which is very nice.
And I have a different
question.
I want to learn playing the
piano myself as well.
LANG LANG: Wonderful.
Wonderful.
That's a great idea, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm pretty
old, you know.
I'm 35.
And my question is actually
two part.
First of all, I heard
about something
called the Suzuki method.
But I heard conflicting
opinions about it.
So I wonder what's
your take on it.
And the second part, is it--
how do you say it?
Real ambition to learn to play
the piano at such a late age?
And to do even something
minimum?
LANG LANG: It's never
too late.
Suzuki method, actually, I
didn't know that method when I
was practicing.
And then later, I
know the method.
But I've been brought up
by just playing scales.
So I didn't really
have any method.
Try this method or not.
I think that maybe it's
important for some people.
But it's not necessary to be
focused on one method.
Because in the end of the day,
there's so many ways of
playing piano.
And you don't want to start
with one thing in the very
beginning, and you're
just stuck with it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but I understood
the Suzuki method,
both the father and the child
are learning together.
I thought that's what--
LANG LANG: My father
also did that.
But it was a different
kind of method.
He's playing, like,
the strict method.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: It doesn't matter.
But I'm sure it will work
for many people.
I just didn't brought
up by that method.
But this is a very challenging
way to know what is the real,
right beginning method for
kids to learn piano?
We'll still trying to
figure that out.
So once I know more about
it, I let you know.
But seriously, you can always
learn piano, no
matter how old you are.
I have a doctor friend.
He's a wonderful doctor,
lives in Germany.
And he's now, I think,
50 years old.
JEFF SPURGEON: Good god, 50.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: Because he always
loved the piano.
But he never had money to learn
when he was very young.
He was focusing on medicine,
you know.
Then somehow, after he became
a very successful doctor, he
wanted to establish his
childhood dream, which is to
play beautiful songs.
And so he started to learn
piano when he turned 42.
Seriously.
And he found a teacher who was
very young, like, early 20s,
but a very good guy, and
a very solid pianist.
So he started learning
from him.
And you what?
This 50-year-old doctor just
made his family archive
recording of 10 of his favorite
pieces, including the
Schumann Traumerei, "Dreaming,"
including the
Schubert Impromptus, including
Chopin's Waltz, including
Liszt Consolation.
So this guy's only learned a
few years, but he has his
golden Top 10.
So he can open a radio show,
you know, Top 10.
And he plays very beautiful.
I mean, the technique maybe
is not really there.
But he's certainly put his
emotions there, which is more
important, somehow.
And so I'm sure you
can do the same.
And I'm sure you're much
younger than he is.
JEFF SPURGEON: One
more question.
You.
AUDIENCE: So given the level
of evocativeness that you
achieve, I have to wonder,
do you have some sort of
meditative practice other
than at the piano?
What are your favorite ways to
tap into, say, greater levels
of humanity?
LANG LANG: I mean, the first
really important thing is
taking naps.
[LAUGHTER]
LANG LANG: You're talking
about meditation, right.
I mean, that's the first thing
that come to my mind.
Because I'm such a night
person, I don't
sleep well in the night.
I just get over in my mind
with some strange ideas.
But during the day, I like to
take a one-hour nap, and then
somehow that calms me down,
and I feel great.
And also, I think the best way
for ourselves to get ready
mentally is reading books.
Read as much as you can.
And also, after reading, take
a little walk in a park.
Or go to museums.
This, for me, is the best
way of learning new
knowledge and relaxing.
And this makes me a much better
musician and a human being.
JEFF SPURGEON: Thank you.
And thanks to everyone
here at Google today.
And thanks to Lang Lang.
Great.
LANG LANG: Thanks.
Thank you.